a thermometer in a science lab displays
the temperature in both Celsius and
Fahrenheit if the mercury in the
thermometer rises 256 degrees Fahrenheit
they're giving us the Fahrenheit
temperature what is the corresponding
Celsius temperature and then they give
us the two formulas that if we know the
Celsius temperature how do we figure out
the Fahrenheit form temperature or if we
know the Fahrenheit temperature how do
we figure out the Celsius temperature
and these are actually derived from each
other and you'll learn more about that
when you do algebra and we also maybe in
another video will explain how to derive
these it's actually kind of interesting
involves a little bit of algebra but
they gave us the formula so they really
just want us to apply it and maybe make
sure we understand which one we should
apply well they're giving us the
Fahrenheit temperature right here so F
is going to be equal to 56 and we need
and they're asking us for the Celsius
temperature so we need to figure out
what the Celsius temperature is well in
this one over here there's if you know
the Fahrenheit temperature then you can
solve for the Celsius temperature so
let's use this right over here
so our Celsius temperature is going to
be five ninths x times the Fahrenheit
temperature the Fahrenheit temperature
is 56 56 degrees Fahrenheit minus 32
minus 32 well 56 minus 32 is 24 so this
is going to be equal to is going to be
equal to 5/9 times 24 times 24 and this
is the same thing as five times 24 over
nine and we can divide the numerator and
the denominator by three so let's do
that if we divide the numerator by 3 and
the denominator we're not changing the
value 24 divided by 3 is 8 9 divided by
3 is 3 so it becomes 5 times 8 which is
40 over 3 degrees and if we want to
write this as a as a number that makes a
little bit more sense in terms of
temperature let's divide 3 into 40
degrees or so sorry let's divide 3 into
40 to get the number of degrees we have
3 goes into 4 one time 1 times 3 is 3
subtract 4 minus 3 is 1 bring down the 0
3 goes into 10 three times 3 times 3
is nine subtract you get a 1 and then
you could bring down another zero we now
have a decimal point over here you're
going to get a zero here 3 goes into
once again 10 three times and this 3 is
going to repeat forever so you could
view this this is equal to this is equal
to thirteen point three three three
it'll just keep repeating this little
line on top means repeating degrees
Celsius or you could say that look three
goes into forty three goes into forty 13
times with a remainder of one with a
remainder of one so you could say that
this is also equal to 13 remainder one
so 13 and one third degrees Celsius
either way it works
but that's our Celsius temperature when
our Fahrenheit temperature is 56 degrees